okay our last example in today's lab is
going to be um so a sort of
non-parametric test procedure rather so
what we've done up to now uh we've been
using these functions T Test from
underscore independent or or related or
various ones from the the SI the Sci-Fi
stats package now the way those tests
are constructed is well some
statistician the T Test goes back to
student at the Guinness Brewery worked
out how you know what's the dist you
know what does a test statistic look
like when the null hypothesis is true
what does the distribution look like and
so they make various assumptions now
those assumptions may or may not be true
so there's often interest in procedures
that work better when the assumptions
may not of the of the T Test may not
specifically hold and so what we're
going to look at here is what sometimes
called a permutation test um well we're
going to build up a null distribution
from the data itself where we assume the
null hypothesis is true and we can use
this distribution as a substitute for
the the T table that the T Test
functions use to construct the P value
the data we're going to use is the con
data uh that we saw in um in our chapter
on unsupervised learning uh that was
last
chapter and so remember there are I
think
uh 2,000 genes and um several patients
patients and they in four classes um and
these are all childhood cancers um in
four different categories
yes okay so
um let's just uh fit the run the T Test
on on one of the uh one of the genes so
we'll take Gene 11 here and we'll
compare Class 2 to class 4 so this
decision about which class to compare is
something that a researcher might will
have made beforehand and we want to
compare um the the micro Ray or the the
genetic data at Gene 11 for the the yal
2 group and the Y equals 4 group and it
constructs A P value here we've even
used this so-called pooled variance by
making this argument equal variance
equals true so now when we interpret
this P value and we look to see whether
it's less than say 5% or not we're
making some assumptions about the way
the the data looks um and uh when those
assumptions hold then there's only a 5%
chance this P value will be less than 5%
if the null were
true so rather than trusting that uh
distribution we're going to make this
resampled one so the what the basis of
this resampling procedure is we assume
the null hypothesis is true that is the
yal 2 group at for Gene 11 is basically
the same in distribution as the yal 4
group in G Gene 11 so then we randomly
reassign uh the data in group two to the
data in group four keeping the the
sample size in group two and group four
the same and then we recompute our T
statistic and by doing this many many
different times we get some idea of
assuming there's no difference between
group two and group four what would the
what are reasonable values for this T
statistic to look like so we're going to
do this 10,000 times here what we're
going to do is um we're going to keep
the uh the you know this earlier we had
the first number of observations were're
in group two and the first other the
remaining were in group four but we're
going to reshuffle the response before
running the test function so that we use
this Shuffle function and we're going to
store the test statistic now we'll have
10,000 test statistics and we can see
how does that compare to our observed
test statistic the P value here is about
again about 004 and that's very very
close to what we saw before almost you
know um if I were if we were to round it
to two decimal places they would they
would
agree or sorry two significant digits
they would agree okay so let's just take
a look at
um the collection of those T statistics
so what what we're plotting here is a
histogram of those
10,000 statistics we computed by
shuffling the data or uh under the null
yes uh and the red curve is the actual T
distribution yeah this is the the curve
that's used to compute that 0.041 P
value so actually for this gene they
they look quite similar yeah um so for
assuming the null distribution looks
quite similar okay and of course this is
for a single Gene but if we could repeat
this construct this histogram for every
Gene and make a non-parametric test for
Every Gene so if we have multiple
geneses then we'll have multiple P
values we could apply bond foroni to
these P values or we could apply homes
procedure or we could apply our um bun
Min hawber procedures this is really
just a different way to get a P value um
that we can later use for the multiple
comparisons so the remain remainder of
the lab um shows how to use these P
values to do false Discovery rate
analysis or the Benjamin hofberg
procedure on these P values but what's
really happening is um we're just using
the this procedure to construct uh new P
values and then running Benjamin hawber
on those so you can see um the final
outcome is the uh uh you know for given
threshold of FDR we again get a list of
uh significantly selected genes the big
difference between the fun example and
this one is just the P values were
computed with a non-parametric test here
rather than than the that T Test
function and we'll leave the remainder
of the lab for you to finish
offline